um you uh for people who don't know I
feel like a lot of people if it wasn't
Griselda they discovered Benny through
you get through you and you and you guys
doing the early collab table is that
2015 yeah like the trust tapes and stuff
like that all that early [ __ ]
um
explain your relation obviously both you
guys are from upstate about an hour
apart Buffalo to Rochester 45 minutes
out
um explain how did you and Benny end up
initially linking up
um I I used to go to DJ Shay Studio
fresh in peace rest in peace the DJ said
I used to go there to record that was
like that was Benny home studio and uh
like green and team Invasion shout out
to Green Lantern and team invasion they
were they they suggested that I go out
to Buffalo to recall at shape spot so
you know early in my career like 2007 I
would go out there and just start
working on my early mixtapes right and
then me and Benny would just collab
because that was his home studio So
eventually it became my home studio as
well and that's how me and Benny ganked
that relationship because I come through
there and we just be working and [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying and uh that's
how I started that's how I met Ben
that's how I met Conway and you know the
whole the whole Griselda [ __ ] yeah I
think you guys are synonymous with each
other both y'all's movements you know in
terms of like what you all do with the
fans which I'll do on the business side
like and then obviously musically I
think you guys are very tied in man
um has it been it's been pretty dope for
you just knowing Benny since back then
to kind of see everything Benny Benny
been one of my main motivations on my
journey and [ __ ] because it was times
that you know on my journey I faced so
many things that would discourage me
from not really you know knowing how to
capitalize off it that I would take
breaks right
and uh watching Benny he just would keep
going we'll keep going and uh
that was the motivation I needed right
so when I seen like the response he was
getting that motivated me it was like oh
I know it's possible you know there's
somebody I work with all the time and I
see how they responded to him so it's
like oh let me show them what I could do
too if if Benny ain't keep working
the way he did I went and had that
motivation or inspiration to really keep
going because like I said
I wasn't making no money off of it after
doing it for 10 years right so you know
once I seen my boy doing
actually getting the respect and the
recognition it was like oh okay we onto
something now and that's when I picked
my pen back up and we did stabbing shot
that was a great project appreciate that